I headed to Stevie's Creole Café
to chop it up
with Karlous Miller,
Amanda Seales,
Bomani Jones,
and Emmanuel Hudson.
If Black Twitter was a club,
they'd all have
their own VIP sections.
What is it about
side chick, side dude humor
that is so enticing?
- Nothing is funnier
than a bad idea, man.
All right?
Like, these--these stories
do not ever end positively.
They tend to always end in ruin.
- Black folks love drama.
And we love comedy.
And so any time
that there's errors,
there's gonna be comedy.
- I'm pretty sure I've
been a--a side dude.
- You didn't know though?
- It wasn't confirmed.
But you get a feeling
in your heart.
- In your gut.
- I ain't
never had no side chick.
I ain't ever been a side dude...
- All right.
- To my--to my knowledge.
- I dated rappers,
so the odds
of me being a side chick
at some point are very high.
- Why are jokes about
side chicks and side dudes
more popular in
the black community
than in other communities?
- Our ability to
always take everything
and turn it into positive
is something that
black folks have been
forced to do,
and so it's just one of
the next things that we do.
- What's she's saying is that
Black Twitter is gumbo, right?
- Mmm, yes.
- And the scraps
are the things that
maybe the mainstream
doesn't deal with,
like side chick humor.
- Yes.
- But we done thrown that
in the roux.
And we over here
feasting on some.
- We cooking.
- And we cooking.
- I think it's more taboo
to white people.
'Cause we know
white people get down.
A white--like a white dude
have a side chick,
and plan to kill his whole
family so he can be with her.
- On Black Twitter, it's really
about the side chick.
- Yes.
- Now, is that a misogynist
kind of situation?
- Yes.
I think it's misogynistic
because it never
ends up being about
the fact that you shouldn't
have a side chick
in the first place.
- The side chick is practice.
How am I gonna know
how to treat you and
what nice places to take you...
- [laughs]
- If I--I can't
be in a relationship
just freestyling, Amanda.
My girl Amanda like seafood.
Me and my side chick
need to come here
on a Thursday afternoon and
see what Stevie's talking about.
I'm not about to bring
my baby to Stevie's
and the gumbo
not the way she like it.
- You listening to a [BLEEP]
with sunglasses on inside.
- Okay--[laughs]
But that [BLEEP]
with the sunglasses
is something like
a Black Twitter pioneer.
- So I made this meme that says
"I might not be
the man crush Monday,
but I smashed on
side [BLEEP] Sunday."
- You may talk about side chicks
Monday through Saturday,
but thanks to Karlous,
Sunday is the day
to appreciate the side dude.
Are these memes--
is this humor
normalizing adultery
within our generation?
- Of course, it normalizes it.
- It ain't normalizing it.
It's what it's been
forever and ever and...
- But it used to
have shame attached to it.
And now it don't.
- Ahh, mm.
- Yeah, but Bill--Bill Clinton
almost got impeached,
but we knew how Bill Clinton got
down a long time before that.
And we made him the president.
- For women, it's never
been a look to be a side chick.
- Yeah--
- Now, hoes be winning.
- You know who's also winning?
Kermit the Frog.
He's pretty much the mayor
of Side Chick Town.
"That moment you see
an old side chick
and she's walking with a kid."
Let's talk about Kermit.
Kermit is from Muppets.
He's not supposed
to be representing
smashing thangs on the side.
- Kermit the Frog
got side chicks.
He drinking Hennessy.
Somebody photoshopped
a cigarette on him.
Like, the places
that I've seen Kermit the Frog,
I was like, "Shit, Kermit,
me too, I relate."
- I think it's
also funny 'cause
it just represents
a loss of innocence.
- Yeah.
- It's like when your parents
get divorced or
when you find out your grandpa
cheated on your grandma once.
And Kermit is here
to be like, "Hey,
"your innocence is over
and real stuff is happening."
- [laughs]
- Sip that tea.
I want you guys to give me
some commitment humor memes
for this picture right here.
- When you find
the perfect neighborhood
to raise your family in.
[buzzer sounds]
With your wife.
Because you're faithful.
[buzzer sounds]
And you don't cheat on her.
- When you and your wife
bought your first home
together.
[buzzer sounds]
- Damn, that ain't funny.
The next meme is
Barack kissing Michelle
in front of an Easter bunny.
- I got one.
"When he went to 'Carrots.'"
[laughs]
[buzzer sounds]
- What?
- You stupid, man.
- You--you failed.
- I--I can't.
- Only thing that I can think of
is like,
"When it's a threesome
and you waiting on your turn."
That's--that's the only--
[laughter]
That's all I see right there.
- That was funny.